all right that's the song right there
that launched the wanted from uk
sensation to international superstars
it's called glad you came and now not to
sound cheesy but we are glad you guys
came here to our studios welcome
congratulations
i want to go over all the names but it's
really confusing to me right now so
let's just get right into the questions
uh the song is number three uh on the
billboard hot 100 chart you're on the
cover of billboard magazine what's it
all been like for you guys over the past
year um pretty overwhelming if i'm
honest with you um it's been pretty
non-stop since we got in the bun really
i mean it went from nothing in the uk to
to being pretty much famous overnight
and was like wow that's um crazy um and
then we went to uh through to europe and
southeast asia and it kind of got bigger
out there and then we had a chance to
come to the states with um justin
bieber's manager scooter brown and yeah
it's um it's been non-stop we'll get to
all that but how does that feel like
you know like you said overnight
happening what does that do for you guys
as young men
um
it's just one of them things you know we
came in we started writing songs and
then you go in the studio you do a song
and
you might think it's good but you never
expect that it's going to be huge and
then when it does happen it's just like
i suppose you just have to embrace it
and enjoy it and we're you know we're
just enjoying the ride at the moment and
uh we wanted to keep going we don't want
to be a one it wonder we want to hang
around for as long as we can overnight
success brings overnight women it's
great
it's really great overnight women
i've never heard that term before yeah
let's elaborate on that one it's a new
term yeah like groupies overnight and
then see you later in the morning
it's only it's only used in boy bands
is that right yeah yeah
yeah well let's talk about this whole
boy band resurgence because you know i
lived through it back in the mid 90s to
late 90s and now you know with one
direction with you guys it's all
happening all over again your and your
thoughts on this
it's great um especially like with us in
one direction being british as well it's
so good so good for england to have two
boyfriends come over to the states and
canada and and do so well on um
and it i feel really proud because
there's so many artists coming over from
england at the moment like you've got
jessie j cole play obviously adele and
people like that
it's good that we're all kind of doing
it together which is like which is
awesome it's like the third british
invasion in a way
yeah back in the 60s then you had one in
the 80s and now we have one in 2012
again yeah fingers crossed it just keeps
going and people don't get bored of it
or dislike it the single no no the
single glad you came shot up the north
american charts after it was featured on
glee um
how were you about that when you found
out the song was going to be featured on
that show that's a huge show in north
america were you pretty pumped about
that yeah we all started going pretty
crazy in the car we phoned note off um
off our manager and was like
what like we've done glee aren't we just
uh we've done chelsea lately at that
point well we did to chelsea lately so
we did two pretty big shows and then we
found out it was going to be yeah we've
done ellen
um
yeah massive shows and was like well
you found it with glee um
you know you've made it when you've done
glee and i was like just arriving
just repeat just repeat what you just
said there that's that was a good that
was a good question i mean when we found
out that wrongly my mate was saying um
you know you know you've made it when
when you've been angry and i said we're
just we've only just arrived in the
states i mean it's ridiculous but we
just feel so fortunate and
um america has just welcomed us with
open arms and it's really humbling but i
guess these are the moments in your
career that you take you from this level
to to the next level was there another
moment that you noticed
happening in your careers over the last
little while that's that that made you
realize well yeah like we're here but
now we're really jumping this ladder um
i think when ellen uh said she wanted to
break us um was a real honor because
i've seen she'd seen our music and and
she obviously liked it
so she got in contact with scooter and
said
i want to be the one to give these boys
their first tv appearance in america and
that for us was amazing because
obviously we all know about ellen and
how big she is and what an influence she
is um
and that that was awesome and i think
getting american idol as well yeah
american idol was the one finding out we
got that that was your site
we could think you know we're doing
pretty well at boys but like
to think that people like simon fuller
and then you know a show like uh
american idol think the same that's
that's pretty cool that's a nice feeling
you mentioned simon but you didn't
mention jennifer lopez you you excited
too she's she's in there
she's on my hit list she's on my wanted
list it was a cheap galc about the
terrible
terrible i was just gonna say she she
seems to be into younger younger men
these days are you going to
maybe try a
hit on her somehow you at the end here
the the
i'm going to give it a little girl
draw a little drink maybe who knows oh
well give it a little dance drink if you
can
terrible
you should be ashamed of yourself
he's just a young man
living life 23 years that's it that's it
i think going to get out have to get
some better pick up lines to get jayla
just be careful with her okay that's all
i'm saying uh you mentioned scooter
earlier justin bieber's manager he's
taking you guys on what what does that
mean for you do you do you guys are you
big fans of justin bieber this is this
is for jay he's a massager
i think uh justin is obviously the most
famous and probably the richest child or
not even a child is a young man now in
the world so to see like his awesome
success and how he's grown as an artist
every day is great and then to have
scooter who obviously is shaping that in
in the greatest way possible is awesome
because he gives just in room to breathe
and do his own thing in the same way
that he lets us do that and i think he's
he is a genius and he's also like a
total dude he's a great man he's cool
you guys also want to elaborate on on
the whole scooter justin connection or
you know
it's it's beautiful it really is
beautiful like it like just said he
really does like there's no joking
though no it's beautiful there's a real
like there's a real there was a real
connection he's seen him grow from like
a 13 year old i thought you'd call him
beautiful no i wasn't calling him
uh he's seen him grow from like a 13
year old child you know i meet up until
like jess had a young man though and
it's it really is and i love justin's
new single i think he's really changed
his own with with the first single of
the new album and i'm really looking
forward to the album no actually i'll
tell you what i i'd love to look through
scooter's contacts on his phone just to
just to scroll through and see who he's
got on there because all the time he's
like yeah i'll give him a call and
you're like
what you'll just call him up i'm not
going to say names or anything kim
kardashian was one i was like give her a
kiss
yeah
bbm it's like oh i see as you do as you
do
speaking of phones and contacts i saw a
couple of you on yours earlier uh
are you on them constantly these days
what are you doing on them uh um
twitter pretty much the fans updated in
stuffing letting them know what we're up
to and where we're gonna be so they can
come and see us and that um and that's
about it really we're just watching some
fun videos before from yesterday but was
that the um
was it the brahm
brumhort
yeah but yeah yeah yeah at the uh yeah
the mall yeah um screaming i heard on
your phone uh yeah it was pretty crazy
um thanks to everyone that turned up
there you've really made our lives nice
um and they were all really nice so
we're just watching a couple of videos
that we're gonna put on our website
sweet you guys have been given this
nickname uh the bad boys of england can
you explain this
why are you the bad boys of england
um i think we got that because
yeah like the the because we're a boy
band and normally there's this uh
stigma attached where you very clean cut
and
you don't drink or you know you don't go
out you just go and rehearse you dance
you do singing lessons
uh we don't really do any of the latter
and we we do like to go out and we like
to party and we have been pictured uh in
pretty bad ways and stuff like that but
i think that's why we've been called
that you know to us we're just normal 18
to 23 year olds but i think we get
called the bad boys because we really
like to party and we're in a boy band so
maybe we are bad boys
as a boy band bad boy but really we're
just normal we do what we do what people
already do now wrong with drinking
you